hello there I don't know why I said it
that way but that's cool let's try
something new this week welcome to the
monitor as always I am Peter Rubin
senior editor at Wired and this week we
are going to talk about the very best
sketch comedy show on television right
now apologies Lorne Michaels we are
going to talk about a handheld video
game that surprisingly isn't is a worthy
successor to its console cousins but
first we're going to talk about looper
the movie that is out this weekend it is
written and directed by ryan johnson who
made brick and he made the brothers
bloom and he also directed a very
special episode of breaking bad but
looper is is amazing looper is amazing
loopers amazing three times maybe you'll
believe me so I actually had the good
fortune to be able to see this movie in
June because i was interviewing ryan
Johnson for the September issue of the
magazine so I saw it in June and I've
kind of had to hold my tongue since then
kind of telling colleagues that trust me
this is amazing and you're gonna love
this movie and now it is finally out
this weekend and I can talk a little bit
more about it Joseph gordon-levitt plays
a hit man whose only job is to kill
people that the mob sends back from the
future time travel has been invented but
it is highly illegal so the only people
who use it are organized crime
syndicates this one in particular is
headed up by jeff daniels in an
incredible performance joseph
gordon-levitt is confronted one day with
his older self played by Bruce Willis
I'm sure you've seen the trailers and
you see how this can see plays out but
Joseph gordon-levitt not only has really
good kind of makeup and prosthetics to
make him look physically more like a
young Bruce Willis but he has
internalized dudes cadences and into
nations perfectly and it is it is really
like Bruce Willis and a young Bruce
Willis are acting in the same scene
together it's pretty mind-blowing ryan
Johnson is just a super able and
confident director and the script is
fantastic and there are some really nice
kind of formal Western influences that
play out throughout the movie both from
your standpoint and the way he shoots
the movie and it is there's also one of
the best child actors i have ever seen
them this thing trust me you are going
to love this movie it is great original
sci-fi it is a conceit that doesn't
necessarily seem that imaginative but
the way that it plays out really really
is it is out this weekend I implore you
to see it make sure this man gets a
mainstream love because he is one of the
best working in Hollywood right now for
my money let's talk about video games
for a change Oh buddy you okay thank you
I am of course as residents of the Bay
Area know standing on the platform
waiting for a BART train whereas I used
to spend this time doing something on my
phone or reading a book goose I now have
something to do on my playstation vita
yes someone has one of those it is a
little big planet for the PlayStation
Vita it is out this week either as a
cartridge or a download which is always
a nice thing in this crazy digital world
of ours it is a conventional
littlebigplanet aventure much like LBP
and lbp2 there is a carding game coming
out for the ps3 later this year but this
is not that this is everyone's favorite
stuffed rag of a hero sackboy and has
many many costumes in an all-new
adventure exploring the world of
carnival yo which has all kinds of
grotesque and creepy carnival influence
characters which is another reason I
like to play it on the train because
then it doesn't give me nightmares at
any rate the the new things obviously
for PlayStation Vita means they've got
touchscreen control means you've got
accelerometer based stuff so there's a
bunch of new functionalities and things
that are that the game has kind of touch
controlled rocket launchers and little
mini games for racing and Tetris
influence things and all kinds of
minigames that branch off from the main
storyline so many of those in fact that
it has inspired me to reinstate our
haiku review of the week so here we go
sack boys in your hand even responds to
your touch wait that sounds creepy so
there you go a little big planet for
Vita it is out this week back to you ok
thanks for that glad to see the haiku is
back that was a little weird let's talk
about a sketch comedy actually let's
talk about sketch comedy shows on Comedy
Central
Chappelle's Show sadly went away they've
had kind of a tough time finding a show
that sticks and when I say a show that
sticks I mean a show that I actually
enjoy you know mind of mencia pretend
time with Nick Swardson the demetri
martin show kind of had its moments John
Benjamin has a van and Michael & Michael
have issues that wasn't really sketch
point being there's finally a show that
does it for me and that show season one
was earlier this year key and Peele this
is Jordan Peele and Keegan Michael key
these are two veterans of madtv another
sketch show that I never really loved
they came out of the Chicago improv
scene and they started working together
a lot on mad tv and they kind of made
this sketch show that started earlier
this year and to my surprise and delight
it was the most imaginative absurd and
high concept sketch that I've seen in a
really really long time they do some
fantastic stuff you may have seen them a
lot recently had a recurring sketch last
year about obama and his anger
translator this guy Luther and because
of the election going on now that's been
getting a lot of play it's been getting
promos on Comedy Central and I think NPR
even did a story on me spot but they are
back this week with season two of the
full show and the full complement of
sketches last year they did this this
thing that was like a battle to the
death between Bobby McFerrin and Michael
Winslow from the police academy movies
they always kind of start with a premise
that surprises you a little bit and they
play it straight but then it escalates
and it escalates and it escalates and
they they just they commit to it with
with so much tenacity that you really
have to hand it to these guys and it
never gets kind of weird for the sake of
weird it's always weird you know in a
thing that's logically consistent with
where they start from but as always
hilarious like this seriously I can't
impress upon you enough how consistently
funny that first season was and the
second season starts this week and from
the few sketches that I've seen
that are going to be on it is a return
to form and if you aren't familiar with
it don't worry there's reruns on Comedy
Central all the time and in in a
departure from network comedy if you
miss an episode it's on Wednesday night
you miss an episode it's always getting
a rerun so you always have a chance to
see the one you missed but at any rate
if you're not familiar it's time to get
familiar key and Peele season two starts
this week I make sure you watch that's
it for the monitor this week as always
you can email us at the monitor at
wired.com with tips suggestions hatred
and love we will be back next week with
more of the very best in pop culture a
button still then inspirational
catchphrase here